Ist das jetzt eine katastrophe oder eine wirklich gute idee eine batterie die auf radioaktivität
basierte forschungsteams weltweit arbeiten daran aus
radioaktivität elektrische energie zu gewinnen und jetzt meldet ein russisches forschungsteam einen überraschenden durchbruch
ein prototyp der fast zehn mal so viel energie fast wie eine vergleichbare
elektrochemische batterie was ist dran an dieser meldung und wie genau soll das funktionieren jetzt ein klick zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Die idee batterien auf basis von radioaktivität zu entwickeln ist nicht neu vor allem in der mitte des letzten jahrhunderts
wurden einzig und allein die positiven seiten der radioaktivität gesehen nicht nur autos flugzeuge und schiffe sollten günstig und schnell
mit atomantrieb laufen sondern beispielsweise auch herzschrittmacher und so entwickelte man schrittmacher die durch eine
radionuklid batterie angetrieben wurden darin enthalten bis zu
200 milligramm plutonium 238 und einen alphastrahler mit einer halbwertszeit von
87 jahren und die batterie funktioniert
folgendermaßen eine thermo säule wurde durch den radioaktiven zerfall erhitzt und eine elektrische spannung
entstand mit der der herzschrittmacher
angetrieben wurde und tatsächlich
die plutonium batterien waren extrem lange haltbar und lieferten jahrzehnte lang strom doch er wisse selbst
plutonium gilt selbst in kleinsten mengen als sehr sehr gefährlich und so nahm man bald wieder abstand von dieser idee
andere entwicklungen in diesem kontext dann meistens nicht praxistauglich
was waren sie einfach viel zu klobig um im alltag eingesetzt zu werden
die neue batterie die jetzt ein russisches forschungsteam entwickelt hat die nutzt radioaktives nicke
63 als energiequelle die halbwertszeit von nickel 63 die liegt bei rund 100 jahren und nur das begrenzt die lebensdauer der batterie
konkret besteht die batterie aus zwei dünnen schichten nickel 63 folie diese sind
eingebettet in diamant schichten und so genannten schottky dioden das sorgt dafür dass der strom nur in eine richtung
fließen kann konkret entsteht der strom wenn nickel
63 zerfällt und
dabei beta teilchen entstehen die crux ball nuklear batterien die wir bislang so kennen es werden nur wenige
elektronen durch den beta zerfall freigesetzt dies wird meist durch den einsatz eines kondensators
wettgemacht er legt sich langsam auf und kann dem strom dann selbst schneller abgeben
er macht die batterien aber klobig und sperrig deswegen hat das russische team auf extrem dünne schichten geachtet
insgesamt misst ihr prototyp nur fünf mal fünf mal dreieinhalb
millimeter das optimierte system kommt letztendlich auf 3 300 milliwatt stunden energieprogramm das ist tatsächlich das zehnfache der
spezifischen energie einer typischen
elektrochemischen batterie ihr maximaler output beträgt 0,93 mikrowatt dass es mehr als vergleichbare
entwicklung bislang erreichen konnten doch dennoch langte es immer noch nicht um beispielsweise ein smartphone überhaupt ans laufen zu kriegen
doch in zukunft erhofft sich das russische forschungsteam
vielfältige einsatzmöglichkeiten
und damit wären wir wieder beim thema herzschrittmachern und anderen implantaten wenn diese werden bislang durch elektrochemische
batterien versorgt und wenn diese leer sind müssen sie durch einen operativen eingriff
entfernt werden ja das ist wirklich ein bisschen
spucke man noch also wenn die batterie leer ist dann muss ich operiert werden ja doch auch hier bietet das große hindernis erst einmal mit
hundertprozentiger sicherheit zu garantieren dass die radioaktivität die patienten keinesfalls
gefährdet eine andere durchaus spannende idee ist es mit solch einer atom batterien satelliten anzutreiben
denn diese würden dann in betrieb sein egal ob er sich tim also der satellit im erdschatten befindet oder nicht
die atom batterien könnten deutlich mehr energie speichern bzw
deutlich kleiner sein als bisherige batterien für satelliten ja wenn ihr keine videos sation zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann hättet mich bei whatsapp
dann um geht ihr die kaputte abo boxee auf youtube und verpasst kein video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir noch vor allen anderen vom neuesten video und zwar täglich gaben sie ihr
kriegt der von mir ne nachricht
bevor es auf youtube online gehen einfach hier draufklicken und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal klicks um social media abonnieren
da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
genau die glocken vergessen und hier gehts weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken die größte batterie der welt bis dann
bleibt dran